calculemos el resultado de 1.86 entre 2
y como siempre pausa el vídeo e
inténtalo por tu cuenta y te daré una
pista intenta pensar 1.86 como un cierto
número de centésimos y después divide el
número entre 2 bien vamos a trabajar
juntos como lo prometí vamos a pensar en
1.86 como una cierta cantidad de
centésimos si nos fijamos en el lugar de
los centésimos solo vemos un 6 pero
podemos ver estos 8 decimos como 80
centésimos
es decir punto 86 es lo mismo que 86
centésimos y cada unidad es 100
centésimos así que en realidad tenemos
186 centésimos así que déjame escribir
que este número de aquí es lo mismo que
186 centésimas
y eso es lo que necesitamos dividir
entre dos ahora bien si queremos dividir
186 de algo entre 2 eso es lo mismo que
dividir 186 entre 2 de ese algo podemos
decir que esto es lo mismo que 186
dividido entre 2 y este será el número
de centésimas que obtendremos de
resultado
así que pondré esto en paréntesis y
escribiré que este es ese tanto de
centésimos y bueno cuál es el resultado
de 186 entre 2 algunos de ustedes podrán
hacerlo en su mente otros tal vez
realicen la división en un papel y la
forma de realizar lo que me gusta es si
quiero dividir 6 unidades entre 2
obtengo 3 unidades y después si quiero
dividir 18 decenas entre 2 eso es lo
mismo que 9 de sendas por lo tanto
obtenemos el resultado 93 también puedes
realizarlo de esta manera y decir
cuántas veces cabe 2 en 186 veamos
2 no cabe en uno así que utilizaremos el
18 cuántas veces cabe el 18 bueno cabe 9
veces
9 por 2 es 18 se resta y obtenemos 0
bajamos el 6 y 2 cabe en 6 3 veces 3 por
12 6 y 6 menos 60 así que no tenemos
residuo de ambas formas obtienes 93 pero
son 93 qué bueno son 93 centésimos de
eso hemos estado hablando por último
tenemos que expresar 93 centésimos como
un decimal como hacemos eso bueno esto
será 0 punto y los 93 centésimos
es lo mismo que 9 décimos y por supuesto
3 centésimos hay que escribirlos en el
lugar de los céntimos
así que tenemos como resultado 0.93 y
podemos escribirlo arriba esto será
igual a 0.93 lo hemos logrado